[Music]  Jenna Dewan Tatum proves she still got  some sexy dance moves 24/7 if I knew all  the seconds if I knew how many seconds  were in the day I'd say that on Monday  Channing Tatum's wife stripped down to  racy lingerie on Instagram sporting this  black strappy bodysuit as she put on a  show on all fours Jenna was joined by  her pal  Alison Fulk in the dance studio she  posted a pink doing her best splits  captioned the band is back together so  fun to play tonight meanwhile the 36  year old actress has been keeping busy  on her new show she co-stars alongside  JLo neo and Derek Hough on NBC's series  world of Dance  it is like boom they come out and  they're ready to win  [Music]  you